[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily could movie
director woody allen still be prosecuted
for child sex crimes
our experts discuss the latest in the
allegations by dylan farrow after the
hbo series allen versus pharaoh
and should a convicted killer owe the
victim's family thousands of dollars the
restitution hearing in the michelle
martinko case
murdered at the mall by jerry burns plus
strikes and dismissals
as questioning of prospective jurors in
the derrick chauvin trial continues
should the jury hear about george
floyd's previous arrests our galilean
gavel coverage
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
the panel of journalists to serve on the
derek shobhan trial is starting to fill
up
as we near the start of testimony in the
george floyd case
law and crimes kim johnson is in
minneapolis and has the latest on jury
selection
brian it's been a slower day when it
comes to selecting a jury in the trial
of derrick
shovin one of strikes and dismissals
earlier four potential jurors were
dismissed
in less than two hours now the strikes
come from the defense which has used
11 of its 15 strikes with
nine jurors seated five more needed
now the defense's second strike of the
day was against a man who has served in
the military and had been trained in
hand-to-hand combat and choke holds
here is the defense attorney eric nelson
grilling him about that take a listen
and as a part of your military
experience you had training in
hand-to-hand combat
and choke holds and things of that
nature
that's correct and would you
be able to kind of abandon your prior
personal experience
and apply that plot apply what is
trained by the minneapolis police
department i'm
able to understand what someone else's
training is and apply that to the
circumstances that they're in
if that's what you're asking
jury selection continues wednesday this
as
defense's request to delay and move the
trial to another location
still hangs in the balance the judge
said that he would consider the motion
given last
week's major announcement of a 27
million dollar settlement from the city
of minneapolis
to george floyd's family now judge peter
cahill also today
said that he plans to bring back the
seven jurors that were selected
last week for re-questioning this
after news of that settlement on friday
was
announced he wants to ask those jurors
on wednesday if they heard about that
settlement
and if it has influenced their opinions
of this
case brian thanks kim and jury selection
is continuing on as the judge is
considering a motion to both delay the
trial
and move it to another county after news
broke of a 27 million dollar settlement
between the city of minneapolis
and george floyd's family there was an
article in the washington post that was
published on march 12th of 2021
wherein the washington post reports that
a minneapolis official
said the city had been concerned that
this announcement could affect the trial
the official who was not authorized to
speak publicly said the city consulted
with hennepin county chief district
judge
todrick barnett who told the city it
could proceed
barnett did not immediately respond to a
request for comment i do think it's
a question of where who made this
decision to announce this
and i think the bottom line is this is a
federal lawsuit
the court was not this court was not
involved and
as i recall in my discussions judge
barnett the answer was
we can't tell you what to do and i think
he expressed the concern that we
have about doing such a thing in the
middle of jury selection
so there was no approval by this court
there we had no authority to approve any
release at this time i just simply am
making the records
i think the city is trying to to try and
uh
dump their responsibility back in the
court where it does not belong
joining us today to break down journey
selection in the trial against derek
shovin
is criminal defense attorney nicole de
board and terry austin
nicole this motion to delay and change
venue is still hanging over the case i
i think the train has kind of left the
station and the judge will just move
forward to start but what do you think
i agree with you and i think the judge's
remedy is smart from
an appellate standpoint as well in that
the judge is saying you know look i'll
let you go back and talk to these same
jurors that you've already selected
again
just to make sure that this new
settlement hasn't impacted their
feelings about the case in any way but i
don't believe that at this point this
judge is going to stop this trial
and delay it any further yeah i think
the judge is smart to kind of conceive
or think about the appellate issues here
terry often times we pick a jury we're
thinking about race and gender they're
always the focal point of jury selection
but one thing that stuck out to me is
the age most of the jury
is in their 20s or 30s how do you see
that playing out during the trial
well it raises an interesting point i
think the fact that the jury pool
is on the younger side at least seven of
the nine jurors
are in their 20s or 30s which is quite
unusual and i think that this could work
against showman if you ask me because
presumably
these younger jurors they may have a
greater affinity
for causes like the black lives matter
cause so
i think the real important issue at the
end of the day is
whether or not these younger juries are
going to be
able to speak their mind and have
influence over
the older jurors nicole real quick your
thoughts about the age of the jury
i totally agree with terry i mean the
reality is is that this is a
generation that has come up with an
appreciation for
social justice causes and you know
they're going to have a different
perspective than older jurors might who
would be coming down to hear this case
yeah and again i think the other two
jurors that we're talking about i
believe are in their 50s so you've got
like terry said seven out of nine in
their 30s or 20s and two of the nine
in their 50s it's going to be an
interesting breakdown still ahead on law
and crime daily jerry burns convicted
killer
of michelle martinko but will he owe her
family a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in restitution
our experts discuss but first should the
derrick children jury hear about george
floyd's previous arrests
the arguments body cam video and judge's
decision next
[Music]
we're back garrett sherman's attorney
wants the jury to hear
about an arrest of george floyd's a year
before he died
law and crime's angela levy is here with
the arguments from both sides
yeah brian derek shovin's lawyer says
that george floyd's behavior during that
2019 arrest
shows a clear mo by him when he
encounters police
but prosecutors say the defense simply
wants to use this prior arrest
to smear george floyd 41
may 6 2019 minneapolis police body
camera video shows officers confronting
george floyd
in the passenger seat of a vehicle keep
your hands where i could
see him derek shovin's lawyer says
floyd's behavior
shows a pattern of using diversions such
as crying
[Music]
and swallowing pills when approached by
police judge cahill had already ruled
the jury wouldn't hear about the arrest
even if it's a modus operandi that is
that is how george floyd
acted when he was confronted by the
police it really isn't relevant
these are different police officers
these similarities are
are incredible i mean it's the exact
same behavior
in two incidents almost exactly one year
apart
chauvin's attorney says things have
changed since the prior ruling
after a second search of the squad car
earlier this year
where chauvin's defense team found
chewed up pills with floyd's dna on them
it's just kind of mind boggling that an
extensive search was not done
until january 2021 the may 2019 body
camera video shows
officers finding pills in a bag owned by
floyd
floyd is taken to a police precinct
where paramedics are called because
floyd has swallowed those pills
you've got a person who is being
specifically told this behavior or you
know
presumably this behavior is putting you
at risk of having a heart attack or a
stroke the state again objected to the
jury seeing the 2019
arrest video calling it prejudicial i
think the
reliance the attempted reliance on habit
tells us a lot about the real
motivations behind this
the desperation of the defense to just
smear mr floyd's character by
uh showing that you know what he
struggled with an opiate
opioid addiction like so many americans
do the issues in this case are the
objective reasonableness of the
officer's conduct
in the way they handled mr floyd whether
he has hypertension
the officers have to deal with their
person their arrestee
as they find them whether it's may 6
2019 or may
25th 2020 emotional state feigned or
emotional state genuine
now the defense attorney says that this
supports his claim
that that interaction with the
paramedics and the discussion about a
heart problem
supports the defense claim that george
floyd actually died of a heart attack or
possibly
even a stroke judge cahill said he will
take this whole issue
under advisement he said there may be a
portion of this tape that could
potentially be relevant
it may be that interaction with the
paramedics but he has not made a final
decision
just yet brian thanks angenet here to
break down the latest argument by the
defense is criminal defense attorney
nicole debord
and terry austin as i understand it you
can't use the previous arrest because
the ultimate question as i think was
kind of pointed out there is what
chauvin
knew or his intent not basically what
floyd did in the past or did in the past
and so to bring up this video i don't
see how it works but we'll see how this
works
uh terry what do you think the value of
the arrest is
and should it come in well i don't think
it should come in and i've got to tell
you i think
eric nelson is really arguing strongly
on behalf of his client chovin he's
trying to say
you know it's a common scheme that this
is his habit there's an absence of
mistake
but the judge did not allow it before
even though
eric nelson said that this was identical
and that it shows how george floyd uses
these illegal substances
i think if it gets in it's only going to
be
on a limited basis and it's going to be
because there might be
some prohibited value and the fact that
it might not be too prejudicial but i
think the judge is going to stick to his
original ruling and maybe keep it out
all right so nicole the judge is kind of
saying maybe we'll see so
is there any way that this 2019 arrest
comes in
i think that terry has really boiled it
down to exactly what nelson is arguing
in terms of
you know look i'm not trying to talk
about his prior criminal conduct i'm
trying to talk about
how this might be more likely that he
died of some other cause
besides at the knee of chauvin he's
trying to say that there may have been a
medical reason
that caused his death that is unrelated
to chauvin's conduct
and you know portions of the video in
terms of an encounter could be
potentially admitted to show
that this type of thing had happened
with him in the past
it'll be interesting to see how that
argument plays out i can see a judge
saying well don't you just want the
medical examiner's report to find that
but
we'll see and jeanette the prosecution
said there is a key difference in the
video from that of the may 2019
to that of the may 2020 video so what is
it
yeah the prosecution you know in the
defense i think they can agree in both
videos
george floyd is being contacted by
police he's being taken into custody
in both instances he ingested pills
so that was very clear however in the
may 2019 arrest
the paramedics were called and he
received treatment
he was monitored they told him look you
know you're really putting yourself at
risk for some serious health issues
doing things like this they monitored
him
and he didn't even need anything to
reverse an overdose or anything like
that and he survived that encounter
yeah the thing that i would be afraid of
as a defense attorney the one major
difference in the 2019 case is there was
no knee on george floyd's neck
he swallowed drugs on both of them but
on one of those occasions he didn't die
so this could potentially backfire on
the defense but we'll see how it plays
out
coming up on law and crime daily
accusations against woody allen are back
in the spotlight
but does that mean he could still face
charges plus
he was found guilty of murdering an 18
year old in a mall parking lot back in
1979.
butcher jerry burns pay michelle
martinko's family thousands of dollars
the judge's ruling you don't want to
miss next
welcome back an iowa man convicted in
1979
murder turned cold case no longer owes
the victim's family tens of thousands of
dollars
prosecutors in cedar rapids say jerry
burns killed then-18-year-old michelle
martinko
when burns was 25. the 40-year-old case
languished until dna tests were invented
and public genealogy databases became
weapons for law enforcement
burns was found guilty of first-degree
murder last year sentenced to life in
prison
and ordered to pay the martinko family
150 thousand dollars
but burns defense says that since iowa's
victim restitution law
did not exist when the murder occurred
decades ago
he should not have to pay the state and
defense
council have reached consensus that it's
inappropriate to apply the
150 thousand dollar restitution in this
case because it would be
you know ex post-facto application of
iowa's restitution laws against mr burns
so first i'd just like to ask for the
court's guidance as to
whether the court would like us to
officially file a motion to correct
illegal sentence
i will prepare an order correcting that
portion of the sentencing order
as i and i will cite in there well i
don't think there's any question if
there is an illegal sentence the court
may correct it on motion or on its own
motion
at any time so i will correct that
portion of the dispositional order to
remove
the order uh directing payment of 150
000
to the heirs of michelle martinko
here to discuss restitution for
convicted murderer jerry burns is
criminal defense attorney nicole de
board and co-host terry austin
nicole no restitution because from what
i understand the law didn't exist when
the crime occurred
basically exposed factos is that
basically it and is that correct
i think it is correct and even though it
strikes us all is very unfair i mean
obviously this person's been found
guilty of the crime and there is now a
provision allowing for restitution
the problem is is that the law at the
time of the crime did not give
a defendant warning that such a
punishment or restitution could be
required
so the judge just has to follow the law
as much as it does seem
painful and unfair yeah you've got to be
able he's aware of the punishment of the
potential punishment
when the crime has occurred uh terry
without the restitution though do you
still
think that the case ended the way it was
supposed to is was justice found
basically
well you know we got some justice
because we did have a conviction of the
individual who murdered michelle
martinko
but i think that the family definitely
deserves some restitution here
there was quite a bit obviously of pain
and suffering here
and even though it cannot be applied
retroactively
i do think that the family has some you
know consultants in the fact that
they have a conviction at the end of the
day though
the restitution would not make any
difference at all
whatsoever it is not going to bring this
young girl back
exactly and and i mean real quick terry
could there potentially be a civil case
could they
seek uh damages there yeah they could do
that i mean we will see what happens but
they could file a claim they could for
wrongful death
i mean that's always a possibility so
we'll see if that happens at this point
it doesn't look like it will
yeah we'll keep eyes on that and maybe
they do have the possibility of getting
that civil claim and maybe
uh getting something from jerry burns
thank you when we come back
allen versus pharaoh the decades-old
saga gets new attention
what that means for alleged victim dylan
farrow and is there
still a possibility of prosecution our
legal analysis after the break
welcome back the hbo docu-series allen v
farrow is bringing the spotlight back on
the decades-old case involving two
famous celebrities
and sexual assault allegations terry
austin has been following the saga
and is now looking into the question
could woody allen still be prosecuted
mia farrow first accused woody allen of
molesting her seven-year-old daughter
dylan
in 1992 alan denies any wrongdoing and
police say they could not find
any evidence of an assault but that
doesn't necessarily mean
it's cased close alan and pharaoh
adopted dylan
and raised her together until the
couple's separation
a videotape surfaced of dylan describing
alan sexually
alan claims pharaoh coached young dylan
to say those things because of his
romantic relationship
with farrell's college age adoptive
daughter sununu previn
the lynchville county connecticut
prosecutor investigated dylan's claims
he explains in allen v farrell that he
strongly believed there had been
probable cause to bring charges against
allen
but he chose not to in order to protect
the girl from further traumatization
the option was clear have alan arrested
go to trial and put the child on the
stand as my
first witness but was it truly in her
best interest
could you give us a comment woody there
was incentive to be drawn
into efforts to discredit my sister this
is a calculated move
in a media war i was so scared i didn't
know what would happen next
so terry walk us through this what
options are still on the table
well brian there are no statute of
limitations for most sex crimes against
children
in connecticut so theoretically even
though the alleged sexual assault
occurred in august of 1992
the victim can still bring criminal
charges against woody allen today in
fact
dylan could even file a civil claim for
personal injury
caused by the sexual assault because she
was under the age of 18
at the time of the assault the real
question is whether dylan will recall
the details of an event which occurred
almost 30 years ago nicole let's bring
you in to discuss
as a former prosecutor do you see a
sitting state's attorney
reopening the case i think it's quite
possible in this circumstance i mean
certainly there's been
a lot of information that is now
accessible that wasn't
previously available to the prosecutor
before you have a witness who is in a
position to
be able to tell the prosecutor whether
or not she remembers or doesn't remember
and whether or not she's going to
participate in a trial
which is a much different thing than
what you have sometimes when you have a
young child who may or may not be able
to testify
yeah and terry i'm not just seeing a
potential reopening
of the case like the criminal case but
what about all those who are tasked with
finding justice for abused children
who turned a blind eye could there be
litigation there
no question about it especially as far
as the state of connecticut is concerned
this all happened in the state of
connecticut and while they did
some investigation they ultimately
decided that there was no reason to move
forward here
and even new york could have done
something they were looking at the
divorce case they were looking at child
custody issues
but they had some inkling that something
was going on here
and you have to think that because it
was woody allen because it was such a
high
profile case that maybe everyone
ultimately
turned a blind eye to what was going on
here
and just allowed it to continue forward
which really means as far as i'm
concerned
there could be some cause of action
against both of the states for failing
to do something on behalf of these
children
yeah and nicole real quick to both of
your points i mean this was
pre harvey weinstein when you didn't
think you could take down a giant
like this do you think that now in 2021
there may be more of an inclination to
go
forward on woody allen's potential
charges i think that's a great point i
think that it's entirely possible that
because
people are more willing to listen to
sort of both sides and the testimony
even about something so awful as child
abuse uh
you know or sexual assault in court the
perspective is going to be different and
a prosecutor may feel that they have a
better opportunity
to get someone to give this case
and thank you for joining us here we'll
see you next time as we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
you